[Musique]
tut tut tut tut tut tut tut tut tut tut
tut tut utilité doit jamais dû mars
sais tu sais gc en vrai et écrira et
décoder le mars et ça non mais c'est
vrai que ça sonnait bien écouter
n'importe quoi tu veux apprendre
ouais c'est ça ouais loïc dit le nain
dit le mot dit le mot a généré gouy non
je ne suis pas allé chez le coiffeur
durant le générique c'est juste pour
vous dire que je donne un coup de pouce
à l'application appy de mon pote jo jol
vous en reparle à la fin de la vidéo on
un concours où je vous fait gagner un
iphone 11 ou le téléphone de votre choix
et des places pour des spectacles et des
livres sur une appli gratuite voilà vous
serez c'est à la fin si vous voulez voir
salut dans la série mentale t-il
aujourd'hui je vous apprends le morse
mais je vous apprends pas comment
apprendre le manche si comme pour
d'autres vidéos comme l'alphabet à
l'envers à la fin que cette vidéo vous
connaîtrez déjà beaucoup beaucoup de
lettres morse directement téléchargées
dans votre cerveau le morse sa a été
créée en 1930 par samuel morse exacte et
c'est un code de communication universel
et qui est vraiment en passe de devenir
atemporel maintenant on alterne des sons
bref et rapide qui une fois qu'on les
décode correspondent à des lettres on a
l'habitude de dire que les cours les
points il se construit et que les longs
les tristes prononcera alors ça serait
plutôt ta ta ta moi je connais sa jolie
loïc merci pour la suite de cette vidéo
il va aussi fier d'écouté et d'imaginer
ce que je vais dire en même temps et on
va on va juste se dire un truc on va se
dire que la voyelle au correspond à lons
dont qatar et que toutes les autres
voyelles elles correspondent à courts
c'est-à-dire type c'est tout c'est pas
compliqué à retenir les voyelles sont
toutes des points sauf le haut une seule
le haut
ça c'est un trait c'est long ces crs en
gros on va créer un code sur le code
pour aider notre cerveau à assimiler le
morceau parce que en fait en faisant ça
il va créer des connexions avec des
données qu'il a déjà 2 présente dans la
mémoire dans
cerveau et donc ça va s'accrocher
beaucoup plus facilement alors le à ces
points tressé tita on peut remplacer le
point par n'importe quel voyelles ça on
le sait est le trait parrot et si on
rajoute des consonnes dans tout ça pour
essayer de faire un mot qu'on connaît on
pourrait se dire que c'est halo avoir un
téléphone
ouais mais ça marche quand même et c'est
vrai ça marche quand même parce que halo
on a bien que deux voyelles de dans le a
et le haut le à bath et n'importe quel
voyelles donc c'est bien le point et le
haut c'est le trait donc si je pensais à
l'eau je pense à hockey à l'eau à eau
donc pointerait c'est tout simple et
surtout ne vous piéger pas ne vous dit
pas alors à temps le à ckoi ah oui c'est
un point dites-vous à c'est pas aux donc
c'est un point c'est tout c'est il ya
que le haut qui fait un changement qui
fait que c'est un trait paul besset plus
dur c'est très points points points donc
il va nous falloir un mot n'importe quel
gaullienne n'importe quel voyage
n'importe quel boyelles et je veux que
ça commence par la lettre b pour que ce
soit plus simple à retenir puisque l'on
parle du b donc on va on va penser à
bonaparte et dans votre tête vous avez
juste à imaginer napoléon pic alors on
tape au héros de polar le sait c'est
très pointerez point qu'on va convertir
en en coca cola comme ça en aoât aux as
rappelez vous un os et un retrait et
n'importe quel os doyelle c'est un point
pour le dr abu carrément alors le death
est très points points
vous voyez le voyage ouais ça marche
carrément bien bravo qu'est ce que ça
marche pas donald ça marche pas comment
ça marche pas bien ça marche pas il
manque une nouvelle donc une voyelle
donald manquait wael ce que c'est trés
points point man qui avait vaincu l'ol
si tu pouvais juste plus précis parce
que je l'a vraiment pour moi je suis
maintenant en fait de cette donald duck
donald duck dans ce registre le dogue ça
fait une voyelle en plus le but donc
c'est bon eu de but et oui bien entendu
le coup tu reprends oui la vidéo pendant
alors pour faciliter la croche dans
votre mémoire je peux vous demander de
retenir quoi que ce soit c'est pas le
but
je veux juste que vous imaginiez et
répéter si c'est possible pour vous de
parler web parce que le but ce n'est pas
de passer pour un psychopathe ou pour
quelqu'un de bizarre pour son entourage
donc imaginez la scène suivante si un
téléphone qui sonne l'ama elle décroche
à fait à l'eau hélas le plan dans votre
tête ceux des zooms et en fait c'est
napoléon bonaparte qui au téléphone et
napoléon il commande au téléphone
bouteille de coca et je voudrais une
bouteille de coca il n'est pas allemand
donc il n'ya pas d'accent et on lui
apporte immédiatement c'est donald qui
lui apporte la bouteille de coca
imaginez bien cette scène bonaparte qui
dit allô et donald qui lui apporte un
coca il ya même pas dedans particulier
un c'est pas un très important
imaginez ça et voilà vous connaissez
déjà je pense que vous rendez compte 15
% du morse comme ça téléchargez dans la
tête je vais le prouver et essayer de
décoder si je vous dis ah comment vous
l'écrivez en morse
je vous laisse deux secondes tut tut tut
tut tut tut tut tut tut tut tut tut tut
du milieu de seconde qui sont passés
loïc a pas assez
allo donc courts longs oui bravo bravo
bravo masques et de loïc n est pas
obligé d'avoir un rire de mec qui veut
dominer l'univers était juste appris de
l'être quand vous voyez comme minus leur
fait jouer à wii vient d'un contexte non
mais alors c'est cortex visuel
tu me trotte toujours bien rigolé l'eau
il n'empêche que tu as fait un perfect
alors on tente maintenant 1 30% ou je
vous donne juste les autres mots moi je
suis dit moi je suis chaud sûr qu'ils
sont choses toujours cette même passion
commune pour télécharger des trucs dans
le cerveau qui servent pas en contre et
ça peut ça peut servir et sauvé la vie
de quelqu'un un jour ans le marin pour
le e c'est très simple point donc voyait
il faut une voyelle quelconque et pour
moi c'est juste et qu'il ya juste une
voyelle etc et pour le fc est un petit
peu plus dur pour un point très points
donc voyez le quelconque voyelles
quelconque aux voiliers lesquels compte
il n'y a pas beaucoup de mots qui
permettent de former sa avec des
consonnes un mot cohérent le seul mot
que j'ai trouvé c'est farandole alors
imaginer plein de gens qui dansent une
farandole c'est une danse de provence
que loïc va vous faire voir tout de
suite
j'ai eu peur que tu danses logique j'ai
vraiment peur de ça qu'est ce que tu
fais la vie des morts les victimes quand
c'est pas du genre juste vous imaginer
plein de gens qui dansaient ça vous fera
penser à farandole le g c'est l'un de
mes préférés attention le g c'est très
très points donc aux voyelles qu'elle
compte que l'on peut convertir
attention en goldorak
c'est génial ou pas vu que j'étais
petite j'adorais ce décès ne regarde des
transferts moi je veux je veux être
votre enfant regarde il court il court
comme ça encore comme ça ils passent
dans les bars ainsi il est déjà dans
goldorak plus tard excuse moi il est
déjà dans goldorak et tous mes idées
dans goldorak version vaisseaux du
cerveau tu vas et là il dit oh la la
ils ont un robot en face il faut que
j'aille dans la tête du robot maintenant
pour passer en mode robot tu vois et
c'est là où j'ai transfert de la tourner
de 180 degrés à temps parce que là il ya
il faut qu'on parle notre poule il
tourne de 180° ok il va dans le petit
corridor avec son petit siège d'accord
arrivé à mi chemin
il refait 1 182 et il va se placer la
tête de golf il a fait un 360 c'est
pourquoi ils ont fait ça parce qu'il
n'aime pas aller en marche arrière au
départ parce que c'est vraiment quelque
chose on est sur une perte de temps pour
quelqu'un qui veut quand même sauver le
monde moi j'ai pas le créer le débat
mais jonas fait polémique
le hc quatre courts poin poin poin poin
donc qu'à doyelle quelconque au choix
alors ça pourrait être hilarité ou
himalaya moi je préfère himalaya perso
donc imaginer dans votre tête une grande
montagne ni moss montagne de quand même
plus de 4 km2 auf à ses os donc
l'himalaya pas si c'est écrit dans le
texte et je vais peut-être même à
l'écran ben alaya non l'himalaya malaya
levée je n'ai vu que ça va c'est mon
côté minus cette île à l'eau amenée -
coca-cola la colère oui maintenant on
passe à l'histoire
on se rappelle également de nouveau que
le haut ça veut dire longs traits et que
toutes les voyelles ses cours et
imaginer qu'il ya une farandole de jean
hockey qui crie vers le ciel et là il ya
goldorak descend alors du ciel et qui se
posent sur la montagne la montagne un
email imaginez vraiment ça fait cet
effort là mental c'est bon pas longtemps
et maintenant on va tout associé vous
pouvez même maintenant vous rappelez de
bonaparte qui dit allô d'un coup il ya
de na li lui apporte un coca mais en
fait ils sont devant l'himalaya et il ya
une farandole de gens qui font l est du
coup il drague qui entend et qui du coup
il arrive et il se pose du coup sûr sur
l'himalaya
c'est pas grand chose mais le fait
d'avoir imaginé ça s'arrange comme dans
votre mémoire épisodique qui facilitent
l'entrée de la mémoire à long terme
du coup je ne sais pas si vous vous
rendez compte mais juste en regardant
cette vidéo vous connaissez maintenant
un tiers du code morse un tiers du co2
mars est énorme ou pas en vrai à des
traits des points et tous qui qui
apprend ça aussi vite
ben vous vous pouvez vous auto l'ikea
les ilic et vous après comme je le
disais au tout début de la vidéo que je
vous télécharge juste une partie dans le
cerveau je vais donc vous laissez des
propositions de correspondance à l'écran
pour les autres lettres
et vous vous pourrez imaginer ça en
faisant poser tranquillement comme vous
le souhaitez alors le hisser points
points donc c'est ici vous pouvez penser
à un gros panneau il y aurait marqué
peut-être un panneau comme dans alice au
pays des merveilles a marqué ici la jc
point très très très alors là c'est une
phrase c'est j'ai un gros bobo vous
pouvez rentrer ça dans votre histoire
qu'à ses traits pointerez donc un
corridor un corridor avec un casse
n'existe pas mais ça marche quand même
tu vois pas ce que ça se prononce pareil
donc un corridor un couloir elle ces
points très points pointent donc
limonade m c'est très très donc moto n
ses traits points donc nouvel os est
très très très alors moi du coup très
très très je prends un ostrogoths dans
ma tête
voilà un autre gros c'est ça pc point
très très points
donc moi je pense à un philosophe un
philosophe grec avec une grosse barbe
q c'est très très pointerez donc
cocorico alors bye cocorico ça s'écrit
avec un slip avec inclus au départ mais
c'est pas grave ça fonctionne rc
pointerait points donc revolver sc
points points pointent donc sabine tc
très donc ton le poisson us et points
points très donc union alors l'union ça
peut être par exemple une bague de
mariage c'est un vigneron ça peut être
un pont aussi qui fait une union entre
plusieurs choses vous faut trouver ses
métaphores bat v on va pas se mentir
c'est le plus dur à retenir alors vous
pouvez essayer de l'apprendre par coeur
moi c'est ce que je fais personnellement
mais sinon ça peut faire poi poi poi
créé le seul truc qui marche est cette
combinaison c'est balpa réseau w ces
points très très donc wagon poste mais
américain xc très points points crée
donc là vous pensez au trocadéro alors
le trocadéro c'est pas pareil c'est bien
conscience de ça mais comme le trocadéro
c'est aussi des carrefours un public les
carrefours yade et il ya des croisements
alors ça fait un x bon trocadéro y c'est
très point très très alors le mieux
c'est yoshimoto et z très très points
points alors là aussi c'est une phrase
un petit peu comme j'ai gros bobos c'est
euros et la zorro et la zorro est arrivé
et donc je rajoute ça pour vous parler
rapidement d'applis epa placement de
produit c'est un placement de copains et
en cette période c'est bien de parler
des bonnes initiatives appli c'est quoi
c'est une application qui existe sur ios
et android qui est complètement gratuite
et qui permet tous les jours de gagner
plein de super cadeaux comme des
téléphones portables des consoles de
jeux des télévisions etc
et comme je parle de l'application
aujourd'hui jol a mis en place deux
concours avec moi donc c'est directement
sur happy 1 pour gagner un iphone 11 ou
le téléphone de votre choix et un autre
pour gagner mes livres en dédicace y est
et des places pour mon spectacle c'est
hyper simple je vous mets le lien vers
la pluie dans la description vous allez
sur mon concours vous cliquez sur
participer
là vous regardez une vidéo de publicité
et boum vous participez et pour
augmenter vos chances et bien vous
pouvez regarder d'autres vidéos de
publicité ou télécharger des
applications ou parrainer des gens en
gros ça marche avec un système de
tickets plus tu as de tickets plus tu as
de chances de gagner d'ailleurs si vous
aviez jamais téléchargé l'application
vous rentrez le code fabien vous mais
aussi dans la description et vous aurez
sans ticket gratuit offert là comme ça
en plus directement
voilà voilà il ya nouveaux savoirs qui
vient d'être téléchargées dans votre
mémoire je vous recommande d'enchaîner
avec avec l'une de ces deux vidéos il y
en a ils vous allez apprendre à dire
l'alphabet à l'envers quand même le peu
mal à la fin de la vidéo vous serez le
faire il ya dans cette vidéo vous
saurais dire le jour de la semaine de
n'importe quelles dates dans l'année un
truc que j'aime bien faire - et si vous
débarquez sur cette chaîne un jeu
90 car vous pouvez vous abonner c'est
gratuit et j'ai dit à un magazine
mensuel dont vous pouvez lire quelques
pages dans la description ça s'appelle
corp news
n'hésitez pas à découvrir sa merci à
tous et à très bientôt